Could the future of renewable energy
lie with a common household chemical?
Ammonia might power your cleaning products
and fertilize your plants, but it could soon
be the carrier for moving energy around the world.
Oil and gas, which make up most of our energy supply,
can easily be shipped and stored.
But renewable energy, which travels through
the power grid as electricity, can’t, preventing it
from becoming a bigger player on the world market.
That’s why researchers are trying to convert
solar and wind energy into liquid ammonia,
which would allow renewables to be stored
and shipped as easily as petroleum products.
But the current process of creating ammonia
is anything but green.
Combining nitrogen molecules,
which are pulled from the air, and hydrogen molecules,
which come from either natural gas or coal,
creates massive amounts of greenhouse gases,
some 1% of CO2 emissions worldwide.
To make truly green ammonia, scientists get their
hydrogen from water by separating
it from oxygen atoms using electricity.
And electricity is what renewables do best.
That means regions with lots of wind and sun,
like Australia, are ground zero for the new
kind of ammonia production.
There, the world’s biggest producer of ammonia
is building a pilot plant that
would rely on solar electricity.
The new plant will feed power from a solar array
into a bank of electrolyzers, which
will convert water into hydrogen.
This won’t produce fully green ammonia because
natural gas will still be used in other parts of the plant.
But it’s a critical first step --
generating hydrogen accounts for half of the CO2
emissions from a standard ammonia production plant.
To succeed in creating truly “green” ammonia,
the industry will have to do away with hybrid
or conventional plants altogether and, instead,
rely on electrochemical cells.
These cells use electricity and catalysts
to knit components of air and water into ammonia,
all without the heat and pressure
normally used to make the chemical.
This isn’t easy - at normal temperaturesand pressures,
you can produce ammonia quickly or efficiently.
But not both.
Now, researchers are trying to create
a single cell that does it all.
Even if they can do it, many challenges remain.
For example, scientists still need to figure out
the best way to extract energy from
liquid ammonia once it arrives at its destination.
But if they can pull it off, this new technology
could be the key to sustainable energy--
all without carbon.